it should be illegal to want your kid to  be famous yeah that should be absolutely  illegal when you look at the numbers  right like there are parents who go I  don't want my kid playing football why  well it could hurt his brain yeah how  could you you let your child be famous  that's an initiative we need to start in  the city no more famous do an audition  and if you bring your kid you get  arrested I like Chris Hanson but for bad  parents yeah exactly Chris Hansen should  do that you can save a lot of kids you  could do it with cash better be like hey  do you want your kid to be the other kid  that the people come and meet and if you  want them to be that actor go to jail go  to jail and then you're there with the  pedophile you guys in the same cell yeah  where you deserve to be yeah  100